hello everyone and welcome to uh well
what can only be described as a
beautiful miniature ruined by the times
we live in uh it's uh quang liam vs
magnus carlson it's from the
quarterfinals of the uh of the earthings
masters and this is game four magnets
one game one uh and then of course the
uh hat bounce back to get uh get back
into the match games three and two ended
in a draw and this is now game four le
has the white pieces uh and he has to
win to force tie breaks otherwise it's
magnus into the semi-final so let's
check it out it's quite a beautiful game
uh really played in the style of the old
masters uh so you guys will enjoy this
one uh so let with the white pieces
opens with d4
we have d5 by magnus c for e6 and now
knight to c3 so nicely developing
queen's gambit declined is on the board
and now magnus goes for the very sharp
tara defense we have c captures on the
e5 and now if magnus wants to play a
nice calm game he could go e characters
on d5 but here he plays c captures on d4
and this is the incredibly sharp shadow
gambit of guitar defense uh and you will
soon see why we have queen to a4 with
check bishop to d7 blocking check and
attacking the queen queen captures on d4
and now e captures on d5 so uh grabbing
the pawn but now queen captures on d5
and now okay uh white one upon but black
will get a lot of development in knight
to f6 attacks the queen and now the
queen can retreat
well a lot of squares but queen to d1 is
considered the safest and the strongest
uh however not the most exciting square
and now okay just bishop to c5 and now
if you look at the position for the
price of one pawn magnus already has two
bishops in the game the knight is
already developed he's ready to castle
and uh well all the developing squares
for for his pieces are very natural and
very easy to
uh to just go for so white still has to
make a few more moves he needs to move
the pawn the bishop the knight and he
needs four more moves to castle at least
so knight to f3 he has to start doing
something about this knight to c6 again
another move another development uh e3
preparing to develop the bishop and now
magnus castle so nicely developing
pieces castling the king we have bishop
to e2 now lays also ready to castle and
the queen to e7 now saying that all
right this rook might come to d8 your
queen is still on d1
so really rapid development we have
castles by la uh and now uh the position
is a known one uh for example rook after
e8 has been played rook eight to d8 has
been played even rook after d8 has been
played uh last year uh alexander grisham
played this against the dingler and uh
he lost the game but it was but it was a
very nice one in the ftx crypto cup uh
but here magnus goes for knight to e5
it's not a new move it has been played
once uh by a fellow norwegian uh
arientari played it um
in 2021 in december against salem saleh
but in that game bishop to d2 was played
and also tari lost this game with black
so here uh
bishop to d2 is a normal but the move uh
let plays the knight to d4 is a known
move so now uh already as of move 13 we
have a completely new game
and now magnus goes back knights to c6
he says uh
well all things considered i only need a
draw to advance uh what do you play here
and also i'm going to put the rook on d8
there will be a lot of pressure on the
knight on d4 so if you want you can
capture on c6 but then i just get my
bishop here and this is now well just
very nice for black so instead we have
a3 preparing further development and the
magnus of course prevents this he plays
a5 and now we play b3 so at some point
we will fianchetto are bishop to this
long diagonal uh rook eight to d8 as the
queen is still on d1 so a very natural
square to develop the rook and now
knight c to b5 and it looks like there's
a lot happening here but white is
actually perfectly fine here and
controlling that knight very well uh
if something like bishop c8 we put more
pressure on the knight here just bishop
b2 this is kind of what the white wanted
so here after knight c to b5 magnus
captures on d4 we have knight
on d4 and now even bishop captures on d4
uh so queen captures on d4 and it looks
like this is exactly what white wants he
wants to trade down now as he is up upon
so you want pieces of the board you want
pawns on the board and now bishop to b5
attacking the bishop and the queen but
again perfectly fine for lay he just
goes queen b2 defends the e2 square so
bishop captures queen captures and now
uh white traded down a lot of pieces but
now magnus gets knight to e4 and now
look at this this knight is on a
beautiful e4 outpost and white does not
have a knight or or knights and he
doesn't have a light square bishop so
how are you ever getting rid of this
knight from e4 one way is to play f3 but
that's weakening your king's position
and that's of course uh what black wants
so here we have a4 uh preventing b5
anytime soon and also preparing bishop
to a3 this would win material so magnus
has to play rook ft e8 which is not a
problem he wants to develop this rook
right away
bishop to a3 attacking the queen while
developing and now queen to e6 putting
pressure on that b3 pawn and now uh le
defends it by advancing it pawn to b4
and now magnus plays rook to d2 so it
looks very scary uh but if something
like queen to e1 then the game just
continues for example b6 and nothing
really uh terrible is happening here uh
white is a little bit passive with the
queen on e1 rook on f1 and he's gonna
have to do something very radical if he
wants to get winning chances here
however after rook to d2 left played
queen to b5 and now there is a problem
uh now the queen is too far away from
the king and now look at this queen and
the rook on the e file going after that
e3 pawn so we just have to imagine that
there is no f2 pawn so you know like
imagine there is no spoon uh only here
the difference is you can actually do
that so here knight captures an f2 by
magnus and now what do you play here uh
the problem is if you capture with the
rook that's an instant loss for example
rook captures we're going to play rook
captures on f2 king captures queen
captures an e3 with check and now it's a
very well known meeting pattern in seven
king f1 now queen to f4 with check we
want to connect uh
this check with with the rook on a1 so
king to g1 we're going to play queen to
d4 with check force the king into the
open and also pick up the the rook here
so king to f1 queen captures on a1 and
now we just go for the mate king f2
we're going to play queen e1 checking f3
queen to e3 checking g4 rook to e4 check
and now king wherever uh we'll get
checkmated let's say by the pawn on g6
so
after this knight captures an f2
capturing with the rook cannot be played
so of course bishop to c1 is played king
captures of course is impossible because
the rogue defense so bishop to c1
attacking the rook uh and now magnus
plays knight the h3 with check so
what do you play here can you capture
the knight well if you capture the
knight then we can checkmate the white
king in in a lot of ways but queen to g6
is the simplest one as the g2 square is
covered by the rook as well so once you
play king to h1 we're gonna deliver
checkmate or you can give up the queen
first then play king h1 and then we
deliver checkmate so the knight cannot
be captured after knight to h3 check so
king the h1
and now magnus just played knight back
to f2 with check king the g1 again rook
captures rook captures is not an option
for white because now your black is just
up material and it's going to be a very
easy win for magnus so after knight you
have to check let repeats king to g1 and
now magnus goes knight back to h3 with
check king to h1 knight staff to check
into g1 and he was in this position on
move 29 that uh magnus and le agreed to
a draw or rather it's a draw by
threefold repetition so now that's why i
say it's a it's a you know sad um uh
moment because uh magnus doesn't need a
win he doesn't need the extra money they
get for winning games in this tournament
but he wants to
advance to the semifinals and uh face
whoever he will face there uh without
even allowing for the possibility of
losing the game which is uh very much
unlike magnus he always tries to play
the absolute best move even when there
are several winning moves he will spend
that extra time to find the winning move
but here he just uh uh he just decided
that it's uh uh
too too much maybe to even allow uh for
the opportunity to arise for for let to
maybe get back into the game uh but for
you guys who are comfortable in your own
homes or maybe sitting in an airport or
you know in a uh
at work not doing work
after knight to h3 check and king to h1
there is a very nice winning idea here
so feel free to pause the video and
finish this brilliancy for magnus while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations i'm finding this uh
well uh
very nice idea and for those who just
want to enjoy the show okay there are a
lot of winning moves roxy to rook f2
those are all very nice uh however a
rook captures on g2 is just uh
crushing and now you can see that once
the queen comes to e4 there's nothing
you can do about this and there is very
little white can do
about the position uh you know in any
way so the idea is once king captures
the rook here then it's a very simple
queen to g2 check king to h1 and now
queen to e4 with check rook to f3 and of
course queen captures an f3 checkmate so
of course this is not something that's
difficult for magnus to calculate uh
however after uh let's say king h1 and
we go for this rook captures and g2
there are a lot of moves that uh white
can play like queen captures on b7 now
the e4 square is guarded
but still
you could just play rook to f2 and the
game continues with black having of
course uh
a completely
winning game
but
it's always possible to make a mistake
and that's why magnus forced a draw here
but uh you know we
definitely had to show it and not allow
this to be like i said ruined by the
times we live in
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and hope a lot of you have
found the winning idea of rook captures
on g2 so congratulations on that uh i
would like to thank richard schwartz
ryan urban cloud strife andre theron and
cypher kicks for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
semi-finals uh and of course uh the
entire event until it finishes uh so and
of course uh
uh uh here are the standings i i don't
wanna uh sorry understandings the uh who
will play against who uh so as you can
see uh nipple defeated vincent he was
also a very fine match so he advances
into the semi-final so yesipenko
defeated eric hansen uh the the game
that we've shown so the semi-final first
match will be nipple versus uh artemia
defeated the ding which was a very very
dramatic event to watch ding won game
one then game two ended in a draw game
three uh ding was completely winning
went from plus seven to minus seven one
move then he lost that game and then
artemi also won the fourth game so
incredible fighter artemy of coming back
from such a terrible position in the
match and as you've seen magnus defeated
lei
by winning game one drawing games three
and two and of course forcing this draw
in game four so we will see nepo versus
yes pencil
artemia versus carlson and then whoever
wins we will see in the finals uh so
yeah uh thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day